he so alen John uh Foundation boy
Workshop in righ North Carolina class
106 uh we were dealing with super super
fundamental stuff today just to get
everybody on the same page um we just
started out by reviewing vase that the
sweep turn and pup turn so spinning
forwards in wheel plane sweeping low
turning around to reverse sweeping High
turning to forwards you can think of a
golf ball being down here on the floor
by your heels sweeping past that and a
bell hanging not over your head hit your
head but off the side maybe over your
shoulder that you're swinging up and
ringing turning
around
um we also emphasize footwork not just
swinging the toy uh good way to to play
with it just with the body is
to keep the arms out of the
Horizon step back opening up to the wall
your feet are open your hands are swung
down and follow through closing the feet
your arms come up the other
Horizon and the idea is that you want to
feel that swing that weight in your
hand and really get the the swing of the
hands and the opening and closing
movement of the body all the happen
so that you're you're not like chasing
after your hands or your you're starting
to go and dragging the hands with you uh
it's
very very
high everything moves in
unison in fact I'm just going to throw
this out there so it's on the
video um a general ergonomic principle
is that for every quarter turn of your
body your arms will go through a quarter
turn of their large Circle so from here
to here here with both a quarter turn of
my body on a compass and uh a quarter
turn of my arms on a clock from here to
here is a quarter turn from here to here
is both arms and body quarter turn from
here to here from here to here from here
to here from here to here of course when
we're doing that in motion and flow
spinning we don't look like a robot
going check check around in the clock
but it's good to become aware of those
alignments those are Focus points you
want to check yourself on so that every
quarter turn of your body you're
checking for the alignment in your body
and your arm
position
um and we sort of you know took took
those ideas back
to checking or
spinning we also practice tuck turns
tuck turns instead of sweeping the front
of your body are allowing your Koy to
come past you behind you and tucking
behind your body so we
did behind the head the shoulders behind
the butt the
armps uh a good practice here is to espe
you over the head sort of
pause and see if you can actually feel
and keep some control of your PO swing
there behind your shoulders and then use
body movement to bring it back
out my SL
that of course it's a little It's Tricky
we can just sort of like dangle our toy
behind your butt so it's maybe a little
harder to practice a little tck turn the
the idea one one way to think about it
is you are swinging your poy past your
body bringing the hands up like
someone's giving you 10 behind the back
lifting the PO up towards your armpit as
you Flur around sweeping off the
shoulders so you could at least
pantomime that holding your poy instead
of swiming pendul so it comes up you're
turning your body and you're sweeping